Hermione's reunification there were
suddenly 16 million more people living
in the federal republic the change was a
huge financial challenge to the health
care and Social Security system the new
citizens were insured from the beginning
also receiving pensions and unemployment
compensation the ailing economy in East
Germany left its mark many factories
were ready for closure and 70% of all
rivers were contaminated the creation of
the unity fund totaling some 80 billion
euros was aimed at financing the new
challenges the first solidarity pact
added another 95 billion euros to clean
up mining areas dismantle nuclear power
plants and renovate buildings it also
funded new roads and railway lines some
work has yet to be done
the second solidarity pact takes effect
in 2019 the government plans to pump
nearly 160 billion euros into the East's
infrastructure experts estimate that
since reunification some two trillion
euros from Berlin and Brussels have been
spent on propping up eastern Germany